tiens tu es meilleur ami depuis trente
ans oui c'est laurent perrigot oui il
fait quoi laurent dans la vie d'oreilles
les producteurs en télé il est il fait
énormément de choses les rencontrer ils
démarraient était très jeune et
desmarais se rende à l'époque je
travaillais avec monsieur laurent le
connais très bien et en fait laurent
c'est un vraiment un ami c'est comme un
frère
eh ben je l'appelle tout de suite rey
jean meyer a ramené de faire travailler
de le faire craquer laurent perrée qu'il
ya ilahi on l'appelle dans la grande
archaïque et nerveux il est il et il est
nerveux il était très cool mais surtout
il adore rire donc j'espère qu'il va pas
très concernés alors oui acheter des
bons alors qu'à laisser caire dimanche
oui et a été chez boulanger ainsi pas
acheter mackinac est capable et ce parce
que tu sais qui c'est y voit à 12h tu
aurais pas manger une salle de basket
est gage d'une paix des coupes y ait un
contre rapide
absolument et soutient là je travaille
on a toujours tout pout prête attrition
[Musique]
toujours des jeunes me pourrit toi et
ces [ __ ] de m'améliorer mais futur à
saint pée mais pas des petits rôles
autrui pas mais avait ma caisse ce qu'il
paraît pas dans la vie est vrai qu'ils
évacuent la personne des mois a toujours
talent ben voilà pinocchio qu'est ce qui
te faire cette merde
cette issue car c'était envers pinocchio
là
tu me cites himmich à la cbc qui n'ont
pas du tout j'adore
il vient de folie alors bien sûr il
c'est cyril hanouna et franchement est
il est très sympathique savamment nos
rangs mais le monde
j'adorais nouveau et les proviseurs
bonjour tout le monde ya le ramacity
t'embrasse lolo ouais merci
[Applaudissements]